All right, if I can have your attention, please we're going
to start off with the word of prayer and then we'll get
started. Let's pray.
Father we thank you for the opportunity.
to belong to something that is going to outlive all of us and
we thank you Father that you've promised us that
as we are making disciples that you're there
with us. And so we thank you for your presence. I pray
Lord that you would convict us where we need to be convicted encourages
where we need to be encouraged and teach us
how to how to make disciples to your glory in Jesus name.
Amen.
So we start tonight with a
new chapter. This is the halfway point.
It's a 12-week series tonight's week 6 everybody
look to the person you're right and say good job.
You notice that they they were not looking at you were
they but anyway, we're glad that
you're here and we are starting a
new kind of a new Direction this chapter
starts the the another chapter on how
to make disciples and tonight. We're going to answer the
first question. We make disciples like Jesus.
All we're after is the concept
of spiritual transformation. We're
interested in more than
information.
And a lot of Bible studies do a great job at informing but
we're interested in more than just information.
We're interested in transformation. You
guys know this better than me. This is our mission statement.
We exist to glorify God. Look at this by becoming
a hub for an all ages
disciple making movement.
In seeing lives transformed in
Edmund. So another thing I won't
spend a lot of time on this but the purpose of
disciple making is not just the transformation of
lives, which of course is the personal
goal. But corporately within
the economy of God as disciple
makers it is the it's those transformed lives
that go on to bring Fuel and energy
and motivation and Manpower and the
kingdom Body of Christ to
do what to build a network of neighborhood churches
in the OKC Metro Area you may
or may not know this but our state
convention.
Is looking to churches like us to help
them with the problem of empty churches.
There are six churches right now that are completely empty owned
by the Southern Baptist convention because
the church body just they just died on
the vine and they just gave their empty building
to the convention. So can you do something and
the convention knows better than just to send somebody over
there and says, hey do best. She can they want a
church that understands the multiplication process
of disciple making disciples That
Make Disciples. So planting churches
in our nation and the metro area and sending
every day missionaries to Gateway cities among the nation.
So our vision and mission statement align
perfectly with Matthew 28
19 and 20 Jesus taught these
four steps. Number one engage explorers
evangelism is
the first step in
Process and so the word there is go the
the tense of
that verb is is kind of as you
are going so discipleship doesn't start and
doesn't start in the fall and stop before the holidays, you
know, A discipleship is ongoing. It's
go you it's not what you do. It's who
you are. And so as you're
going your normal routine is making disciples.
I know this. Okay. I
know the culture. I know you're busy. I
know if we were to ask you to belong to another
program you'd say I just don't have time. I'm
not asking you to get involved in another
program. I'm asking you to understand that this is
a lifelong commitment to being
involved in disciple making either being
made as people pour into you or taking what God
has given you and pouring into others and so engaging
explorers is the first step.
Connecting Believers is the next step. Go there
go there for Make Disciples of all Nations baptizing them
baptism is the the first
step of obedience and new Believers
are included into this Community of Faith through
baptism. And but then what do we
do? We work to include them into a community group. We know
that we must connect new Believers. You
can read this on your own but in your curriculum, you'll see
that that the church is like
a family
All right, and a brand new baby needs a
mama and daddy. All right, you say no they
just need the mama. Well the mama would disagree mom would say I need
your help Daddy. And so we my
mom my wife and I we used to team up. I
remember one night. It has nothing to do with the curriculum and
I don't even know why I'm telling it our oldest
daughter had a cold of some sort and we
needed to give her some Tylenol and so my job was to
go get the shrins of Tylenol and I put it in there
and you ever seen the doctors how they'll
get the air out of it, you know.
So I'm hurrying because the baby
is sick and the mother is motivated for
the husband to be in there. And so I'm hurrying and
I'm trying to get the the air out of the top of it and I squirt
red Tylenol juice all over the kitchen ceiling. All
right. So anyway, we want
to get them involved in a better family than
ours was right.
But so why because they need care and affection
and attention and protection and so that's
why we get them connected as Believers. All right. So who
would like to I have not done this anybody want
to volunteer to come up here and explain to me the pathway
the discipleship pathway in Henderson
Hills Baptist Church. I'll give you three seconds to decide to
I can't believe you're gonna let me stand up here. So disappointed. Okay. So
what we're gonna do is we're going to
talk about how we're not just satisfied with
people coming to worship on Sundays that we want to get them
connected in community. But Community itself is
helpful. But this is our sweet spot. We're outside
of community relationships are built and
intentional leader creates a relationship with someone
who needs to grow in their faith and together. They
work at growing at what this
is the next piece.
Growing disciples how to train disciple
makers to walk with god. Well, how do you do that?
go there for
and all that
making disciples baptizing them and teaching them
to observe everything. I've commanded you. So
we're what we're
trying to do is disciples. Learn how to engage God's word
on their own.
We had a moment.
in a meeting recently where people were
complaining about
The meal that they were receiving on Sunday.
All right, and I'm not talking about the cafe.
I'm talking about the the teacher
the preacher the person delivering the
word the milk the meat they
were like I don't think I like it. And and I
think I said
You know when I was about three years old I started using
my own fort.
And I didn't need anybody to feed me after that. We'll see that's what
we're working at doing. We're we're working
it at teaching a disciple maker to walk
with God. Frankly. This is my favorite
way to make disciples eventually we
will have
Some curriculum that you can use is 12 six-week curriculum
that you can use you can pick it up at the bookstore. You can
start your new microgroup that way but my favorite way to
do it is for us all to decide. Alright, let's study
a book of the Bible together this week. We're going
to study the we're going to start with the Gospel of John. We're going
to read the first chapter of John every day. We're gonna
make notes in our Bibles about what God
is teaching Us in the first chapter and then when we get together,
we're gonna talk about what God revealed to us in his word.
So it holds us accountable to read
the scripture.
It also holds us accountable to report what God has taught
us so that we don't just respond but we
apply and so you have a built-in to
this this growing discipleship
process and accountability where we're
literally learning what God is teaching
us through his Spirit, but we're also cultivating a personal
relationship through prayer. This is
one of the great things about a micro group is you guys are going to
be able to pray together you're going to be able to report about
things that you probably couldn't report about in your community group
because you're kind of embarrassed about them, you know, I need
you to pray for me because something you wouldn't share in
a public situation. So that's that's
the third thing now remember
We're doing this because we believe that a disciple is one
who is following Jesus one that is being changed by
Jesus. That's a transformation and one that's
committed to the mission of Jesus disciple making so that's
that's what we're working at doing is connecting Believers
and growing disciples. The fourth step is
this we want to go multiply and
that means this is an implied in the Great
Commission in Matthew 28 that Jesus implies that
once disciples are connected and growing
spiritually then there to be released
and deployed the multiply their life into others.
I told you about Rusty Watson.
I just met Rusty over an email and we
met at the IHOP and our very
first meeting we're sitting down together. I've got a six-week curriculum
called starting point and I give them
their curriculum. It's very Mechanicals just
like a program, but I said that night. I mean that morning
at the IHOP. I said guys if we're still meeting together
in two years, I'm gonna be very disappointed. They look
at me like why I said because at that point you're supposed
to be running your own group.
and
Then I kind of you know, I would revisit it on occasion and
then I would ask them to teach and I would ask them to lead the prayer before,
you know, I'll know it about a year later Rusty says
Phil can what can I set in the car with you for a minute? This is
not always a good thing when you're a pastor.
When somebody says gonna have a private moment with your pastor, you're about to
hear bad news, right? But what rusty said
is is you remember when we first met you said
one day you would hope that we would lead our own
group.
And I said, I remember that he goes, I think it's time for
me to try that and I said Rusty. I'm so proud of you.
I said I think you can do this and so he was
in a community group at our church. We called him
life groups. It wasn't Life Church. It was Prestonwood Baptist. And anyway,
he started with
some men that he already knew in our community
group who they're good guys. These are
not bad guys. These are just guys who had never had someone
challenging them about growing deeper in their
face with Christ. And so they all agreed to meet and so
they started meeting in a different IHOP just down the street.
And I met later too. They were retired guys. And so
if they started meeting and they started
enjoying one another and then Rusty kind of got frustrated because
they weren't progressing at the same rate. And so
he started going back to his old Bible study. Well guess what happened?
The new group of guys called him and said what's going on?
Where'd you go?
You're our leader.
And you know what? He did he said
Yeah, you're right. I'll be there to I'll be there tomorrow. I'm sorry.
And I'm still in all these text streams. You
know, I'm still I've been gone long enough. I still get all these text messages
and I private texted Rusty and I said Rusty. I'm
so proud of you. You didn't give up on these guys.
You kind of wanted to but he anyway see.
If you look at it, you're beginning to realize right away.
This isn't a program didn't have a start date didn't have a stop
date. In fact, we had a leader who wanted to quit.
But a team of guys around him is like not oh quit us.
We love this.
So it's it's a life style. They're growing
and they're multiplying they're expected to see maturity multiplies.
It just does you plant
the seed the seed grows why to bear
fruit?
John 15:8 by this. My father is glorified that
you bear much fruit, and so
prove to be my disciples.
So that is the four-step process
in your Curriculum by Craig Etheridge called investing in
a few and then I want to do this in
the next five to 10 minutes. I want to talk a little
bit about
Mark 8. If you have your Bibles turn to Mark 8, we're not
going to do this because there's no time for it. But I think you know what
I want you to say or through here. Okay. All right.
So in Mark 8 several things happened that caused
Jesus to speak specifically to how important
he thinks this commission to make disciples is
this is the first thing Pharisees came out
to begin to argue with Jesus demanding of him a sign
from Heaven to test him but sighing deeply
in his Spirit. He said why does this generation demand a
sign? I assure you no sign will be
given it so they ask for a sign. It seems
to bother Jesus Oh what kind of a sign
are they wanting? You know, he's already fed thousands twice.
The deaf are hearing the blind or sing.
The lepers are being made clean the demon possessive free and
setting up what's really going on. Well the
Pharisees listen to me the Pharisees are determined to
Define Jesus in their own mind.
They're not willing to see Jesus on
jesus' terms. They're only willing to see Jesus on
their terms. They have a pretty sweet
deal with a Roman government.
Herod's going to let them rule as long as they can
maintain.
Authority and control over people like Jesus so Jesus
comes in and he can do signs and now people are all fired
up about it and the Pharisees are losing control. And so
they're going to try to trip Jesus up.
And so they're determined to go their own
way, and they're determined to keep Jesus in his
place.
So later.
In the chapter Jesus left them the Pharisees and
got on board the boat again went to the other side and they'd gotten
to take bread the disciples forgot to bring bread on
the boat. Okay. Now he's fed 4,000. He's
fed 5,000 the disciples getting the boat. They forget the bread.
sounds a lot like the church office sometimes but
he commanded them.
Let me tell you what what if I'd have been Jesus I'd have
said how many of you
to eat
Is eating important to you?
You know, that's that's not what Jesus does. He's like
who forgets bread and that's
what I do not want Jesus does Jesus says this watch out?
And Beware of the yeast of the Pharisees and
the yeast of Herod.
Don't you understand don't you comprehend?
Is your heart heartened? Do you
have eyes and Nazi? Do you have ears and not here?
And do you not remember Jesus seems upset about something.
He warns the disciples to Beware of
the yeast of the Pharisees. So what is the yeast of
the Pharisees? It's it's refusing to
see Jesus for whom he is.
It's defining Jesus in your
own terms instead of Define letting Jesus Define himself in
your own life.
You guys know about yeast. It just takes a tiny little
bit and then it starts this fermentation process and it
literally firms or poisons or
infects the entire love so that it all Rises.
And that's what happens. I'm convinced that in
a church. If we're not careful, we can
redefine jesus' Great Commission in ways that
we're really not making disciples, but we're okay with it.
And so I think that's why Jesus is so upset that
the Pharisees wanted to set up their own kingdom for their
own benefit continue their relationship with
Rome and not not upset the apple cart.
But Jesus is not going to allow that.
And so Jesus is warning his disciples.
Don't be determined to go your own way. Don't
be poisoned by your own selfishness. Don't
let laziness or confusion or
fear or anything else ferment your
faith in a way that you don't do what I've asked
you to do and then
Something very significant occurs and Mark 8:27.
Jesus went out as with his
disciples do the villages accessory of Philippi Carolina. I've
been there it is a very very religious place,
but it's full of pagan Idols the pan God and
they did human sacrifices there. And so
He asked his disciples in the middle of all of this confusion. Okay,
I would say this could
be like him down in the middle of Las Vegas
at on the Strip. All right,
and he says who do people say that I am and
they answered him some say John the Baptist others say
Elijah one of the prophets, but you he asked
them who do you say that? I am and Peter answered
you are the Messiah. So this
is huge. This is so key
if you by the way Peter gets it, right.
He says you're the Messiah. So knowing Jesus following Jesus
being transformed by Jesus. I mean
committed the mission of Jesus. This is who we're following. He
is the Messiah but in doing
so we need to understand that there's risk involved because
Jesus is not just saying hey got a good idea if you guys
got some extra time.
You know, he's saying No, this is what we commit Our Lives to.
That we're involved in something that that has
Eternal consequences.
Now that you understand that I'm the Messiah. I
want you to see something very very key. And that
is that I will suffer many things and be rejected by
the elders and the chief priests and the scribes and be killed
and Rise after three days. He presents the
gospel to them and then in verse 33, he says
summoning the crowd along with his disciples. He said to them now
listen and this is sorry I couldn't
do this on week, two three or four or five but here we
are about halfway through we have to decide are we gonna believe this
or not?
Are we gonna obey this or not? Are we
gonna see discipleship through our lens as friends
of the Roman government or whatever are we going to redefine it?
But look at what Jesus says, he says if anyone wants
to be my follower.
That's a disciple. He must number one deny
himself.
Number two take up his cross and number
three follow me.
Whoever wants to save his life will lose it. But whoever
loses his life because of me and the gospel will save
it.
Three steps here.
If you want to be effective disciple maker number one deny yourself.
Say no to selfish interests.
Say no to familiar securities.
Why is denying yourself so important because
Jesus is asking us to rearrange our life around
his priorities around his command his goals
and his purposes.
Step. Number one is denying your plan and obeying his
plan. Step. Number two is take up your cross. What
did Jesus do before he hung on the cross? They
gave him the cross to do what?
To carry he has to carry his
own cross through the city. Why is that important?
Because it was a way for the Roman government to
establish publicly who was in charge.
He's carrying his cross because we told him to.
It's a public admission of submission. You
say well, nobody makes Jesus admit. No, Jesus. Did it
himself? Nobody makes Jesus man. He did it himself. He's like I'm
laying down my life.
So when he says take up your cross, this is
an expression of submission.
Jesus is saying to be my disciple to follow me.
It's going to cost you something.
You're going to have to give something up in order to do this.
Then he goes on to explain what are the consequences if you
don't follow me if you don't persistently continually and
daily follow me as disciplemaker. What
are the consequences for refusing? What has it
benefit for a man to gain the whole world and yet loses life.
What can a man give an exchange for his life or whoever is
ashamed of me in my words in this adulterous and
sinful Nation? The son of man will also be
ashamed of him when he comes in glory.
Glory of his father with the Holy Angels
So Jesus is driving home. This point
that to be a disciple maker is costly and
following me is costly it's
not a casual thing. It's reorienting your
life and your priorities and totally
selling out to Jesus and his command to make
disciples.
And I don't know what that means for you.
I really don't I do know this that Henderson
Hills has been a great church for very very long time. And
as a result, then we have a very rich
and robust history of 60 years of
doing certain things a certain way and there's just
no room for anything else.
Sometimes it feels like that.
And so I'm not asking you to quit everything.
I'm just saying what is it going to take? What
is it going to cost you in order to begin a relationship with a
small group of people whose life you can pour into an
invest in so maybe you can see Eternal consequences and
see Jesus reproduced in their lives
and then the lives of others and then the lives of others because then and
only then are we going to become an all ages to stop
making movement where we can fill up empty churches
with people who make disciples who make disciples.